cool so uh now that we're at the start
of week five of the quarter um figured
to give a little bit of a road map so
so far we've seen multitask learning and
transfer learning Basics and then we
covered some of the core metal learning
algorithms and last week we covered core
unsupervised pre-training algorithms and
really at this point we'll start to dive
into slightly more advanced topics and
um in particular this week we're going
to focus on two different Advanced meta
learning topics today we're going to be
talking about task construction and some
challenges that can come up and also
some opportunities for constructing
tasks in different ways and on Wednesday
we'll be talking about large-scale meta
optimization
and ways that you can
do things at a larger scale basically
and then next week we'll be talking
about some Bayesian metal learning ideas
including actually a bit of a kind of
Crash Course on variational inference
which I think should be should be useful
for at least either as a refresher for
some of you but also for other people
something that's really useful to know
about if you aren't familiar with it
already
awesome so um today we're going to be
talking about task construction and
really the question of the day will be
how should we Define tasks for meta
learning in order to get good
performance
and so this is going to cover
um both a problem that can arise in
metal learning which is often referred
to as memorization and it happens when
tasks are constructed in a particular
way
and then we'll also talk about not just
a problem but also an interesting
opportunity of trying to construct tasks
from unlabeled data and augment the set
of tasks that you have available
um the first part of the lecture will be
covered in in homework four homework 4
is optional but if you do choose to do
that then a lot of the stuff that we'll
talk about in the first half of the
lecture is quite relevant for that
uh and so the goals for the the end of
the lecture is to understand when
memorization can happen in meta learning
and also understand techniques for
constructing tasks automatically
awesome so um first let's recap a little
bit of what we've covered so far and in
particular I mentioned trying to clarify
some of the terminology so this is the
terminology that we've been using in
class where
um in all the lectures where essentially
the kind of we have a set of tasks we
have a set of meditating tasks and a set
of meta testing tasks and everything in
the green boxes on the left is a
training data set or a support set per
task and everything in the red box is
what we use to measure generalization
and this is referred to often as the
test set for that task or the query set
for that task
um and one thing that we noted was that
you can sort of we're actually using
these like these test sets on the top
during The Meta training process so
we're sort of training on the test set
um but we're not we're still evaluating
on something that is completely new
which is are these new held out metatest
tasks
now one clarification and one point of
confusion that came up is sometimes in
the homeworks we were referring to meta
training as and metatest as sometimes
being referred to as train and test
um this is really confusing and
ambiguous uh and so it's something that
will uh try to fix uh in future
iterations of the course uh and
to somewhat try to make it less
ambiguous in the homework the the train
sets were referred to support and query
um and and so that was differentiating
from train and test but it also already
still somewhat confusing and hopefully
this clarification helps resolve some
confusion there
awesome
um and then
beyond the the setup we've talked about
Black Box meta learning where the key
idea is to parametrize a learner as a
neural network
and this network is the inner loop of
the metal learning process it learns
from a few examples sometimes this
learning process is also called in
context learning and you'll see that
terminology used a lot in the NLP
literature and also used in homework 3.
and then when we actually go about
training this neural network to learn
from these examples
um that's the meta learning process or
the outer loop process
um the benefits of Black Box metal
learning is that it's very expressive
you can represent this inner loop can
represent a wide range of learning
procedures but the downside is that it
can be a challenging optimization
problem which you probably saw in
homework one
we've also covered optimization-based
meta learning that embeds gradient
descent inside the metal learning
process this incorporates the structure
of optimization that we know and love
but it requires a second order
optimization and so in homework 2 you
may have found that that second order
optimization can be can make it slower
or a little bit harder to deal with
um and then lastly we also talked about
non-parametric Metal learning
where you create an embedding of all of
your examples and then do some form of
nearest neighbors uh to compare the test
example with your training examples and
output the label that you think of the
example that you think you're closest to
um
great and so as you are hopefully seeing
in homework homework too this can be
easier to optimize and computationally
faster but it is largely restricted to
classification problems
um and then lastly in terms of the task
construction process
what we've seen in the first two
homeworks is is kind of endway
classification problem but the same
ideas can be applied to having different
tasks correspond to different regions
um or corresponding to different
robotics tasks
uh and in kind of all of these settings
you need to construct a set of tasks
using a significant amount of labeled
data
great um so now let's talk a little bit
about
um kind of the main topic of this
lecture which is um memorization and
unsupervised medal learning and so I'd
like to start this off with a bit of a
thought exercise for you
and in particular uh this is kind of a
one picture of a black box metal learner
that takes his input a training data set
and a test input and gives you a
predicted label for that test input
and the thought exercise is
um
when you have you train this on a set of
tasks each task is indexed by I
and
one thing you could consider doing is
passing in the task index a one-hot
identifier of the task index into your
black box meta learner
and my thought exercise first is
um when you pass in both the train data
set and the task identifier uh what
would happen during meta training
um
so the the response was it might learn
to associate the task identifier and the
training data set and memorize it what
is it oh just so like remember the
another answer oh I mean
I mean all of that stuff is really
complicated
yeah so the examples that show up in the
training data set are are pretty
complicated whereas this one hot Vector
is not very complicated and so what it
might do is it might learn to rely on
the task identifier rather than using
the training data
um and during meditating this probably
um isn't a problem
um basically it might just learn to rely
on this task identifier instead
basically the task identifier and the
training data are redundant they both
encode information about the task
um
and then my next question is
if it does start to rely on this task
identifier what would happen at meta
test time if you pass in
a new training data set and a task
identifier for a new task and so this
would be a one hot vector for a one hot
Vector that's different than the one hot
vectors that I saw during training in
particularly during meta training
yeah
performance would probably be really
terrible because it would try to rely on
the task identifier again but since it's
a one-hot representation it has no
correspondence with any of the ones that
seemed before yeah so the answer was
the performance would probably be pretty
terrible because the one hot Vector for
the new task is different from any of
the one hot vectors it saw before and
because it's relying on that it wouldn't
be able to actually perform the new task
um so it won't in some it won't
generalize to the new task so okay this
seems like
um kind of an initial thought exercise
now
a second thought exercise
um what if instead of giving it a one
hot Vector what if we gave it a
paragraph
that describes
um what the
what it should do uh like how to do the
task or what the task is
does anyone have thoughts on what would
happen
during meta training and perhaps also
during meta testing
it depends on how
depends what's going on what thing is
going to be more complicated where
the problems
situation yeah so the paragraph is going
to be a lot more complicated than a
one-hot vector and what it depends what
the network decides to use will depend
on how complicated the paragraph is
versus how complicated it is to discern
the task from the training data and so
it depends on basically whether it's
easier for the neural network to use the
description or to use the data
um and similarly if um in terms of
generalization to new tasks in some ways
it depends on what it decides to use
during meta training and also the
structure of that paragraph it may be
that it can actually generalize to the
new task using the paragraph description
if it has kind of learned sufficiently
General representations of natural
language text but it could also be that
the maybe it sees a new word in the new
paragraph for the new task task that it
hasn't seen before and it can't
interpret what the goal of the task is
okay so these are two two initial
thought exercises
um and to start kind of getting you
thinking a little bit now
um the key problem that arises in both
of these thought exercises is that the
model can minimize the meta training
loss without actually looking at
the support center without actually
looking at the training data for your
task and this means that it won't
actually necessarily learn a learning
procedure
that relies on that training data
um and so if we go back to how we've
been constructing tasks for a few shot
classification problems
um
typically we'll do it something like
this where for task one we sample some
images we assign some labels uh kind of
an arbitrary or random way but we make
sure that the labels are consistent
between training and test or between
support and query
and likewise for the
um for the second task we'll again
sample a new set of of labels
arbitrarily assigned
um
labels to images and we'll do this for
each of the tasks
and one thing that you can note here is
when we do this
across different tasks the piano class
for example has a label of four for the
first task and it has a label of three
for this for the third task
and so this means that when we randomly
assign class labels to image classes for
each task the tasks are mutually
exclusive
and what I mean by that is there doesn't
exist a single neural network that can
classify the images in task one and the
class of and the images in class three
um because you have a fundamentally a
different label being assigned to the
same image class
and as a result of the fact that the
tasks are being are mutually exclusive
it means that in order to actually solve
and be able to minimize the meta
training loss
they have to actually use the training
data they have to look at the assignment
of labels to images in the training data
in order to accurately make predictions
on the test sets or the query sets
cool everyone following
foreign
now the third thought exercise is what
if we assigned labels in a way that was
consistent across tasks
and so in particular
say that we assigned the labels like
this and
what I mean by consistent is I mean that
the image class of
um of piano or the image class of this
breed of dog is always going to be the
same across all of the tasks
and so
this means that the tasks are not
mutually exclusive and a single function
could solve all of the tasks
and so then my question to you is
[Music]
um
is what would happen in this case
yeah so just like the previous thought
exercises
you would still memorize and you
wouldn't actually learn how to learn
because you can just learn a single
function that classifies rather than
relying on the support of data
please
would that result in a problem
um you're saying that you're asking is
it also a problem that for the query
images you would have seen them in the
support
so the question is um in some cases like
the same images is in the query set in
some top for some tasks in the support
set for other tasks
um and also this this class is appearing
multiple times
um that's actually not a problem and I I
would guess that most for most of you
the way that you implemented homework
one you may have actually had it had
images appear sometimes in the support
set and sometimes in the query set you
can get a little bit more out of your
data if you have it appear in have it be
allowed to be appearing in either the
support center the query set
um cool so in this case the network can
just learn to classify the inputs
irrespective of the training set
um
and so in particular what can happen is
that when you train a black box metal
learner it can basically learn to just
ignore this input and just classify
based off of the the x-test based on the
the query example
and likewise even for an optimization
based meta learner it could also learn
to basically ignore this and primarily
rely on on just the initial Network in
order to make predictions
a little bit more difficult in this case
because it actually has to like learn
how to ignore the gradient descent step
but it can figure out um it can also
figure out how to do that
yeah
assigning multiple images
[Music]
yeah that's a great question so the
question was um
one thing you may have noted here is
that there there are actually multiple
meanings like even though the labeling
is consistent
um there are multiple meanings for a
given label so like
4 means both a Carousel and a piano for
example and so this does mean that the
network does need to have enough
capacity in order to be able to kind of
lump those Concepts together uh and
we'll actually see start to see some
experiments and this may also start to
hint towards some solutions to the
problem
cool
um so we can ignore things and if you
actually run
um if you run meta training on this
exact example that I gave you and then
evaluate it on examples from new classes
its ability to learn from a new data set
um
the accuracy
goes to around 7.8 percent or 50 percent
in these two different problems um and
this is for for the mammal algorithm so
it's even something that has to use a
gradient descent step and so it's
actually writing fine tuning at test
time
um it's not it's just not giving you a
very accurate
um accurate model on these new classes
if you did evaluate on the classes it
saw during training it would be able to
give you good accuracy because those are
classes that it saw
cool um so then there's this question of
okay
we're not shuffling the labels
um and we don't Shuffle the labels this
is a big problem our performance really
plummets
but is this actually a problem in
practice
and for image classification we can just
Shuffle the labels we
it's
um
it's something that we can do it's also
very easy to do and so it's not really a
problem for image classification
problems
like I mentioned it's also not a problem
if you see the same image classes
as what you saw during meta training
um but it is actually going to be a
problem in in some cases if you want to
be able to adopt with data for new tasks
and if you aren't looking at problems
exactly like some of the few shot
classification problems that we saw
before and that we've seen in the
homeworks
so let's look at a few a few examples
where this may actually be a problem
so
um
this first example is um a robotics task
so say we want different tasks are going
to correspond to manipulating objects in
different ways so one task might be to
close the drawer another task might be
to pick up the hammer and and hit a nail
another toss might be to stack these two
blocks this seems like a very
natural task distribution for a meta
Learning System
and maybe kind of the the new task the
metatest task is to close the Box
now this is a case where this can be a
problem um it can be a problem in a
couple different scenarios one is that
if you're doing this from image
observations
uh
the system can just look at the initial
image
see what's in the initial image if it
sees that there is an open drawer in the
initial image then the task is to close
the drawer or if it sees that there is a
hammer in front of a nail then the toss
must be to hammer the nail
uh and so that's one scenario where
it doesn't actually have to metal learn
in order to minimize the meta training
loss
another scenario is maybe we want to
um maybe we aren't in an image-based
setting maybe it kind of just gets some
waypoints or maybe
um the initial image is somewhat
ambiguous
we might be in a scenario where maybe we
want to tell it like give it a language
description of what the task is like
close the drawer or or Hammer the the
hammer
in those cases if you also give it a
task description which should be helpful
we're giving it more information that
will also make it much harder to
generalize to a new task
um so this is one example
um
one more example uh let's consider a
pose prediction task so say you want to
predict the orientation of an object in
an image
um
and so maybe your Mediterranean task
you're predicting the orientation of a
couch another case you're predicting the
orientation of uh I think this is a very
old monitor or television
uh and then at a test time you want to
be able to predict the orientation of a
chair
um this is also a case where you can
kind of look at the image and you don't
actually need the meta training data in
order to be able to predict the
orientation but if you give it a new
object it may be ambiguous what the
canonical orientation of that object is
and because of that ambiguity it
actually you do want it to actually look
at the meta training set or sorry the
support set or the training set for that
test task in order to
um to actually figure out what the
canonical orientation is and and how to
predict the orientation of the object
thank you
cool um so this is another example where
memorization can occur and in this case
it would memorize the canonical
orientations of the objects seen during
meta training and it would uh no longer
it wouldn't be able to figure out what
the canonical orientation of the new
um the new objects are because it it
didn't actually learn to pay attention
to the support set
cool
um so do people agree that this is a
problem
cool okay
more or less
um now there's a question of whether we
can actually do something about this
um and so to think about whether we can
do something about it let's try to
formalize the problem a little bit more
um
and in particular we saw that if the
tasks are mutually exclusive then a
single function cannot solve all of the
tasks and this could be due to label
shuffling it could be due to hiding
information and in this setting the um
the meddling process will not memorize
and you should be able to generalize to
new tasks
on the flip side if the tasks are not
mutually exclusive
then a single function can solve all the
tasks and it can just
um it can just ignore the training data
and in this latter case memorization can
occur and the reason why memorization
can occur is that there's actually
multiple solutions to The Meta learning
problem there's multiple ways to
minimize the meta training loss function
um and in particular
if we view the metal learning process as
taking as input the training and the
training data set and the test input and
relying on our meta parameters Theta
um one solution to the pose example
would be to memorize the canonical pose
information in your meta parameters and
ignore the support set
and then another solution which is one
that we would often want if we want to
generalize is to carry no information
about canonical pose information in
Theta and instead try to acquire it from
the task training set
and um so here are two sessions and in
general there's actually going to be an
entire spectrum of solutions where you
could
um based on how the information flows so
you could store some information in
Theta and some and acquire some
information from the support Set uh and
likewise
um and basically there's kind of a
spectrum of Solutions in between these
two extremes although in practice you'll
probably get either one of these two
extremes
yeah
uh when you're doing the training
wouldn't you have picked some of our
ambition set which has like some objects
which are not seen and like when you're
using the hyper parameters of
optimization strength optimization all
towards the underestimation part because
we have variations and configurable
options
yeah so the question is um if we have a
kind of a meta validation side or a set
of validation tasks
uh we should be able to tell if our if
our model is generalizing to new tasks
and as a result maybe we can tune the
hyper parameters in some way in order to
actually encourage it to generalize
better uh and
um in general uh
absolutely you'll see that it won't
generalize to validation tasks the
tricky part is how do you tune the hyper
parameters in order to actually get it
to generalize versus not generalize
um and so the you can you can diagnose
this sort of problem with held out
validation tasks but you cannot
um you can't necessarily solve it uh you
you can maybe try to tweak the learning
rate in some way to try to kind of uh
try to get it to do the right thing but
in general It's tricky to do it
um purely based on like learning rate or
purely based off of like the size of the
architecture
um so the question was if you kind of
pass this into a hyper parameter
Optimizer it wouldn't would it be able
to fix this problem and it really
depends on the hyper parameters that you
expose to the model
um
and in particular we're going to need
some form of regularization to encourage
this to not happen I guess the other
thing that I'll mention is in general uh
in general I see this solution happen
more than the solution uh and the
um and I think that that's because
acquiring information from D train can
be an imperfect process
you actually have to acquire it from a
more complex object and as a result
oftentimes you can actually get a
slightly lower meta training error with
the solution than with the solution
cool
um so
if we view it as
um if we view this kind of from the
standpoint of how the information is
flowing we might be able to think about
trying to control that information flow
and in particular
um we can we think of uh
The Meta training process as
something like this
and the um
there's like a number of different
there's basically three objects that you
can use to get a prediction there's
information in Theta information and D
train and information in x-test
and the um we're primarily going to
focus on on the first two information
and Theta and information in D train
and
when we think about like how D train and
Theta
affect the uh the corresponding
prediction
we can try to think about basically
encouraging it to use this this
information more so than using the
information from Theta
now
one thing that would be nice to do is if
we could um
try to maximize the information the
mutual information between the
support set and the prediction
if we could maximize that Mutual
information I think that that would give
us exactly what we want because the um
because then we'd be encouraging it to
use information from D train
um and this wouldn't in any way be
competing with optimizing The Meta
training loss
but unfortunately optimizing Mutual
information like actually estimating
this and optimizing it is pretty
difficult
uh and then so instead
what we're going to try to do is
try to minimize the information coming
from Theta
and that's something that's easier to do
of course if we only minimize the
information coming from Theta
then we won't be able to uh do things
well yeah
the question is can I clarify what I
mean between maximizing the mutual
information between the support set and
the the query set prediction
um
I guess I mean that in the kind of
mathematical sense so if you view these
as two different random variables then
you can Define the mutual information
um between
two variables Like A and B as I guess
there's a number of different ways to
Define it but like one way to define it
is in terms of
um like the entropy of two different
variables another way to define it is
the
kale Divergence between the
uh The Joint distribution and the
um
The Joint distribution and the kind of
the product of the marginals and
basically Mutual information is going to
be telling you like
how interrelated are these two random
variables
and
the
if they're completely independent then
they have zero Mutual information
um
and by actually trying to maximize that
Mutual information it means that we want
y to actually change when D train
changes
uh and so if we're able to maximize that
quantity that means that when we change
D train y will actually change and that
means that it will actually rely on D
train rather than completely ignoring it
I
sorry can you I missed like one word in
the first part is Theta the
um
the general information about shared
tasks and they will again fine tune with
the training data set that we have
yeah so you can think of data as the
shared information
um although in this case I'm actually
just referring to it as The Meta
parameters like the the parameters that
you're optimizing during The Meta
training process
um but yeah when you think of it as a
random variable sometimes it can be
helpful to think of it also in terms of
the
um kind of the shared structure but here
really I'm referring to it as the um
as the metatrading parameters
cool
um
so it'd be awesome if we could maximize
the mutual information because then we'd
be telling it to rely on D train to
basically make different predictions for
different D train
um unfortunately it's difficult to
optimize that quantity
um and so instead what we can try to do
is to
minimize information coming from Theta
and of course we can't only opt like
because if we did that then um
we wouldn't store any information in
data at all and we then wouldn't be able
to do very well we just basically be
learning from scratch in that case
and so instead what we're going to do is
we're going to try to minimize
the information in Theta and also
minimize the meta training loss
and we'll need to balance those two
terms such that
um
such that we're getting a kind of a
Mediterranean loss that we're happy with
um while also trying to minimize the the
information in Theta as much as we can
now
the way that we actually go about doing
this
um relies on kind of
some knowledge of what's called an
information bottleneck and we'll
actually be covering information
bottlenecks on Monday next week
um
so I don't want to go too much into it
right now but the intuition behind what
we'll be doing is
we're essentially just going to be
adding noise to Theta
and um
when you add noise to Theta you're
removing information
from from what's in Theta you're
increasing the entropy of that random
variable
and so by doing so by basically trying
to minimize training loss under a noisy
minimized meta training loss under a
noisy version of data that means that
you're going to be trying to basically
telling it to be able to do meta
training with less information in Theta
as compared to previously
um and so this kind of specific equation
for what this will look like is you have
your meta training loss function
um that I've just written out as L here
and
the um
the way that you write out a typical
information bottleneck is the kale
Divergence between your distribution
over Theta and some prior distribution
which is just a um
which is just a kind of a standard
gaussian distribution and the reason why
this corresponds to adding noise is Q is
going to be a gaussian distribution with
a mean of theta and a variance of kind
of a diagonal uh
variants and so
um gaussian distribution basically is a
sample from that gaussian distribution
it corresponds to adding noise to the
mean of the ocean distribution and hence
why you can think about it as adding
noise to the variable
um and so essentially what this is going
to do is it's going to try to place
precedence on using information from
the support set over using information
from data because using information from
data is not going to be harder because
now you have to use information from
Theta after it's after noise has been
added to Theta and you resample the
noise every time you use the The Meta
parameters Theta
particularly
actually put like a I wasn't lost
and then minimize it
so that's it for you so for example you
can actually try to break the label so
far from like because when you're
generally meet us we know which the
conflict are coming from right so you
can always understand that price to
basically with the information
yeah it's an interesting idea so um
here we're just kind of blindly trying
to add noise and reduce information from
Theta maybe we can be try to do it in a
slightly more targeted Way by trying to
kind of explicitly say you shouldn't be
able to predict
um the info like the memorized
information from Theta
um you were suggesting that you
shouldn't be able to predict the kind of
the so the task the task identifier
which wouldn't quite work
um the tricky part is that like in the
in the pose example the memories
information basically corresponds to
um the canonical orientation of each of
the meta training objects and it has it
for all the objects
um
and it's it's a well I don't see any way
to to try to hit that information in a
targeted way
um but we could also discuss it and if
if any good ideas come out of it then it
could be interesting to explore
yeah
that's your support set from for The
Meta parameters and then try to predict
the test identifier
uh for that and that would restrict your
information about the tax conversation
in the matter Brokers so you're saying
that
um are you saying to like erase this
arrow and have an arrow from here to
here or are you saying to add add an
arrow from D train to Theta and then I'm
just trying to from one possible
initiation of what my colleague said it
was would be to take us away over
support um data point and password
parameters and then go to activations
learn a neural network that will try to
predict the task identifier
and that would restrict your
stored information about tasks in
English
meta parameters
yeah so you could try to have something
like on on top of the activations
um that basically has it such that it
can't predict the task identifier from
that the tricky part is you don't want
to restrict information from D train in
any way you only want to restrict it
from Theta not from D train
um but maybe we can also discuss it a
little bit more after class
cool
um now this um this lot this regularizer
um the that adds noise to to weights
um it's actually used in other parts of
deep learning it's often referred to as
uh kind of Base by Brock prop where
you're basically imposing a gaussian
distribution on the weights of a neural
network
um and once you define this regularizer
which is basically just adding noise to
the weights you can really combine it
with your favorite metal learning
algorithm and it's applicable to any of
the algorithms that we've talked about
in this class
cool um so how well does this work so I
mentioned that
um this sort of regularizer is actually
it's been used in kind of standard deep
learning
um it hasn't actually been that
successful in standard deep learning
usually you can get kind of a few
percentage Improvement
um
but if we look at the metal learning
settings it actually tends to have a
more drastic effect
so for example if you take
um the Omni glot data set which you've
been working with in your homework and
you remove the label shuffling such that
the labels are consistent across tasks
we'll refer to this as non-mutually
exclusive Omni glot
um the original mammal algorithm in this
case will get very low performance
there's another work that proposed a
form of regularization that may actually
be somewhat similar to what was
suggested but it also doesn't doesn't
work very well
um whereas if you do this approach of
adding noise to the weights
uh you're actually able to recover a lot
of the performance in comparison to
using label shuffling
um and similarly on the post-production
task
um which is more interesting than the
omniot tasks it's harder to
um it's harder to just Shuffle the
labels
if you look at the mean squared error
between the predicted orientation and
the correct orientation we see that we
can get a much lower mean squared error
when incorporating the um this kind of
form of meta regularization
and you see the Improvement both with
the mail algorithm as well as an
algorithm called conditional neural
processes which are a form of a black
box bed learner
yeah
was if we subsequently this argument
like acts around those two all of the
weeks
um how else compared to just like
essentially keeping uh the earlier
layers of the network
but then just communicating the last
layer
so then you have to really like
the final prediction task
but it still like learns the future so
it's kind of like the protonettes in
that sense yeah so the question is um
how would so this is adding noise to all
the weights how would this compare to
um kind of meditating the earlier layers
as normal but then like always
reinitializing the last layer and you'd
also do that during meta training right
and then fully train the last layer in
the Inner Loop yeah so
um
I think that something like that would
hmm
off the top of my head I think that
something like that would work
um in general things like prototypical
networks actually often don't suffer
from this memorization problem because
you're forcing it to do nearest
neighbors it has to it has to use that
learning algorithm and
um it's much more difficult to kind of
memorize like how to map from inputs to
labels when you literally have to like
do these sorts of nearest neighbor
comparisons and so given the relation to
things like prototypical networks I
would expect that to work especially for
classification
um I might have to think about it a
little bit more for aggression but uh I
suspect that something like that might
work because
um
because you're forcing it to
to learn part of the network from
scratch
in the Inner Loop but I may also need to
think about it more to yeah
yeah what's the intuition I guess
between adding noise versus something
like Dropout I guess I guess similar
yeah so the question is what's the
difference between adding noise versus
something like dropout
um the in this paper we actually looked
at adding noise to the weights and also
adding noise to the activations and
something like Dropout is going to be a
lot more similar to adding noise to the
activations and we found that
um
we found that adding noise to the
activations actually worked in some
cases but didn't work well in all cases
um and so the reason why there's a w
here is is kind of refers to diagnosis
of the weights versus adding noise to
the activations and so you can see the
activations results in the paper
um
the
part of the challenge with adding noise
to the activations or doing something
like Dropout is um
it can still I guess it depends on like
which
um which layer you add noise to but the
um
essentially say you have a neural
network
um
that is making predictions about a
corresponding input
um
the so and let's say you kind of decide
to like I don't know try to add noise
here or maybe you can even just add
noise and let's okay still see you add
noise right here
um
you're basically just trying to like
minimize and have less information here
but what the network can do is
especially for classification tasks the
amount of information in a label is very
small
if you have if you're doing like 10 Way
classification then it's uh just uh log
10.
and so if you're trying to minimize
information in the activations
it can actually minimize information
just by like basically stuffing the
label here and that's very very little
information that it needs to store
that's actually less information that
what than what it needs to memorize
um and so
I don't know if that was the most clear
clear explanation but basically
[Music]
um
it's the kind of the place where it's
memorizing is really in the weights of
this neural network and not in the
activations of the sterile Network
but the short answer is it works a lot
better on the weights than the
activations
cool
um and then
yeah I guess we don't have Dropout in
these comparisons but um you could also
just try applying things like weight
Decay
um or a version of Base by Brock prop uh
and we see that it works much better
um
it works much better with the kind of
regularization that we've talked about
cool
um now one thing that I'd like to
briefly mention for people who are more
theoretically inclined and want to dig a
little bit deeper into this is um
this form of regularizer you could ask
like we've seen in practice it really
improves generalization a lot but does
it actually do so kind of in a more
provable sense
and there's a way to kind of basically
derive a generalization bound
uh for this approach and it looks rather
complicated something like this
um but basically what this amounts to is
we're trying to bound the generalization
error or basically how well will this
meta training algorithm generalize to
new meta test tasks so that's the left
hand side the right hand side is a bound
on the error and so this corresponds to
the error on The Meta training set
plus the generalization Gap
and this term in the generalization Gap
is exactly the
um the meta regularization that we're
applying when we add noise to the
weights
um so really the gist of this is that
um
the um you could actually theoretically
show that you could actually you can
bound the generalization error and
actually improve generalization or at
least you're bound on the generalization
by using this form of regularization
cool
um
so to summarize the memorization problem
we talked about this
um basically this form of overfitting
and meta learning where you're
memorizing a mapping from X to Y you're
memorizing a function
uh and basically you're memorizing yeah
the X to Y function rather than actually
using the training data rather than
learning to learn
um
and this is analogous to standard
overfitting and supervised learning
where you instead of memorizing
functions you're memorizing individual
training data points
um and similarly you can sort of think
of
um kind of meta regularization as also
being analogous to standard
regularization and supervised learning
[Music]
um
although in supervised learning you're
kind of regularizing the hypothesis
class you can also
um think of this as regularizing the
hypothesis class of the meta learner
and this is a particular interpretation
of controlling information flow
um and the you can view the kind of the
specific meta regularization that we
talked about as Trying to minimize the
description length of the meta
parameters
and so these are also
somewhat analogous although like I
briefly mentioned before we actually see
a much more drastic improvement from
applying these this regularization in
some meta learning problems in
comparison to kind of standard
regularization in deep learning
any questions on memorization yeah
that's a great question do I want to go
into that
um I guess I put it on the slide
so
description length is um
maybe I shouldn't have put it on the
slide um I
I think I'd rather not go into it now
but happy to talk about it in office
hours
um and if you're interested in learning
more you can read up on the mdl
principle which is the minimum
description length principle and um and
Colma Gore of complexity
um and I guess the gist of it is it's
thinking about the length of the program
that it takes in order to express a um
a function the length of the minimum
program
Yeah so basically it's a measure of
information
cool
um Okay so we've talked about a problem
that comes up if you construct tasks in
a certain way and I'd encourage you to
um for those of you that are doing
projects along the lines of few shop
meta learning I'd Encourage Yourself to
kind of
ask yourself
um if your project if this sort of issue
might come up in your project
and if so you can maybe consider
revising your project or or think about
the regularization techniques that we've
talked about or possibly develop a new
regularization technique
um cool and then the second part of this
lecture
um I'd like to talk a little bit about
um
task well another form of task
construction which is unsupervised task
Construction
um
and earlier in this lecture we we
Revisited a few different examples of
classification imitation learning and uh
and
um land cover classification
and these are all scenarios where we
assume that we have labeled data from
lots of different tasks
and there might be scenarios where we
only have unlabeled data or maybe we
have a mix of unlabeled data and labeled
data
um last week we talked about a class of
approaches that can handle the setting
where we only have labeled data during
pre-training and we did this with
different unsupervised pre-training
algorithms like contrastive learning and
like vast Auto encoders and we
pre-trained a representation and then
fine-tune something on top of that
representation
um and today I we're going to talk about
algorithms that are actually end up
looking very similar to those previous
algorithms except instead of just
running fine tuning on top of the
representation we're actually going to
be doing explicit meta learning and
doing the same kind of few shot learning
that we've seen in algorithms like black
box meta learning and non-parametric
methods and so forth
and the
the general recipe
um for
this algorithm is going to be something
like we are given an unlabeled data set
then we will propose tasks from that
data set
and then run meta learning
on the tasks that we proposed
and this is going to look a lot like the
recipe that we saw for
um for contrastive learning as well uh
where we are basically constructing
tasks using different augmentation
functions
of course the key step here is this
middle step it's easy to get well given
unlabeled data is just a given running
by alerting is what we've already talked
about over the past few weeks
so the big question is how do we propose
tasks
and um
yeah our goal will be to try to
automatically construct construct tasks
from unlabeled data
um now I'm curious if anyone has
thoughts on if you were to try to kind
of set out some desiderata for a set of
tasks
do you have thoughts on what you would
want generally that task set to look
like
yeah
it depends on the data
um
similar instances should be like the
same class and then I would like to have
a wireless like set of labels for my
classes and I I don't know yeah so for
him it's going to depend a bit on the
data definitely
um and also it's going to depend a bit
on the tasks so if at meta test time you
expect to be doing a 10-way
classification task then the tasks you
construct during this process will be
different than if you think you're going
to be doing like a thousand way
classification
um and so you want to construct things
that look similar to what you are going
to see at metatest time you can also
Imagine doing something similar to
contrastive learning
[Music]
to individually because part of the
cluster and the difference between those
clusters
did you look at the next slide
yeah so to repeat the um
I guess the
maybe to summarize um maybe we want the
tasks to be something like kind of like
what you get from k-means to be somewhat
distinct from each other
um while also being somewhat diverse I
guess
so um yeah what I put on the sides is I
think that we really want two key
criteria
um one is that we want the task to be
pretty diverse
we want them and the reason why we want
this is that we want them to be able to
cover the test the test house that we
are likely to see
during meta test time um and of course
if you know information about what
you're going to see about meta test time
like if it's 10 Way versus a thousand
way you can incorporate that and
actually make it less diverse to make it
more similar to that and the second
thing you want is you want it to have
some structure so if you propose
completely random tasks uh
then your metal learner won't actually
be able to learn those tasks with a few
examples and this movie gets a little
bit at the k-means comment a little bit
which is that
um
if you cluster data kind of intuitively
what that's doing is kind of finding the
structure underlying the data and we can
try to leverage that structure when um
during the kind of medal learning
process
is there a way to formally define
covering the test tasks
um
it's easy to Define in if you can
represent the task distribution in a
parametric manner
if there is kind of some yeah parameter
underlying the task distribution then
you can kind of say is this in the
support of the distribution
if the tasks are not possible to
describe in a parametric manner if
they're kind of more non-parametric like
one task is to like pick up a shoe
another test is to push a chair
like maybe you can parametrize the shape
of the chair and the shape of the shoe
but in general that's something that's
much harder to characterize
foreign
so we'll talk about how we might
um try to recover diverse and structured
tasks both for image data and Text data
um
this is really the main overview slide
and then on the next few slides we'll
basically just go through a few examples
for how and walk through examples for
constructing tasks that maybe look like
this and also like how these algorithms
are used in practice
um so the first example will actually be
using something a lot like k-means
clustering
uh and in particular we're going to be
doing this with images and if you just
have image observations
it's hard to run clustering on Raw
pixels
and so what we'll first do is run
unsupervised learning in order to get
some embedding space a lower dimensional
embedding space
and once we have this lower dimensional
embedding space it's going to be much
easier to construct tasks
and in particular if we want to
construct a classification task then we
can
find different clusters in this
embedding space and Define a task as
discriminating between examples from
those clusters
so for example one task one three-way
classification task would be to be able
to classify between purple examples
green examples and orange examples
and another task might be to classify
between like the red dash cluster and
the yellow dash cluster
and
by running clustering to get these tasks
we're going to get parts of the space
that have a little bit more structure
in contrast we just randomly kind of
sliced like hyperplanes like decision
boundaries through this space they may
end up kind of
um getting much less structure because
you may get kind of two examples that
are very close together but they'll
actually have different labels
um and so in particular uh to propose a
task once we have this embedding space
we first sample
if we want to to do a two-way
classification task we sample two
clusters so like the red cluster and the
blue cluster
we sample two images from those two
clusters
um so the blue image and the red image
and then that will give us a support set
for that task and then to get a query
set we then sample two additional
examples from each of those clusters and
get a corresponding
query set for that task
and then once we go and try to sample
another task we can simply sample
another set of clusters like the purple
cluster and the green cluster
and then if we wanted to sample these
are two-way classification tasks if we
want to do an ny classification task
then we can sample n clusters and
discriminate between examples from those
n clusters
and you can note that these um
these tasks don't correspond to exactly
categorizing different like typical
image categories but they still have a
lot of structure to them for example the
first task corresponds to like
classifying if something is like a
circular shape versus if you have a pair
of objects
and the second is uh maybe classifying
wine bottles or maybe
bottles of Beverages and um and
something that also has a particular
kind of shape
cool
um and then once we have defined these
tasks we just run meta learning on those
tasks
um so this is one way to get tasks that
are fairly diverse and have are fairly
structured
uh and the result of this process should
be a a representation or a metal earned
model that is particularly well suited
for Downstream view shot classification
tasks
and it should be something that's
actually better than the initial
representation that we used in Step One
and the reason for that is we're
explicitly going to be optimizing for
few shot generalization in these
examples and uh kind of few shot and way
classification depending on whatever
um whatever form of end-way
classification we set up in step two
and so there's a few different ways to
actually instantiate the different steps
here so the first step we could use some
unsupervised learning methods this paper
is a couple years old so it's going to
use uh
some unsupervised learning methods that
are a couple years old but you can also
plug in something more recent as well
clustering to automatically construct
tasks for unsupervised meta learning or
cactus
and then
um you can combine this with the meta
learning algorithm that operates on
those tasks like mammal or prototypical
Networks
and then the we can look at some of the
results so
we looked at
using this approach to construct tasks
in combination with both mammal and
prototypical networks and so if you
combine Cactus with mammal this is the
result that you get
and we evaluated on Mini imagenet which
uh if you give it full labels you get an
accuracy of 62 percent
if you just do I guess you can first
evaluate a few different unsupervised
baselines
which just corresponded to doing K
nearest neighbors logistic regression or
an MLP on top of the pre-trained
representation
and you get a few shot accuracy that's
pretty low in around 30 percent
um you can also do something that uses
clustering
and in contrast if you actually
run this approach to construct the tasks
and do meta learning on top of those
tasks you get an accuracy that's much
higher around 51 percent
um and if you use a representation
that's a bit better the Deep cluster
representation you actually do even
better than that
foreign
oh are you specifically referring to
this method right here yeah
Yeah
so basically all four of these methods
correspond to different ways of using
the unsupervised representation on its
own
um and basically using different kinds
of
um yeah like classifiers or something on
top of that
yeah
so are they labels are tester meta
tester
oh awesome question yeah are there
labels at metatest time
so in this case there are uh 25 labeled
examples at metatest time so the meta
training set is completely unlabeled and
then at meta test time you run it the
same exact way as
um kind of normal labeled meta training
time where you get are given a very
small training data set in this case of
like 25 examples five examples of five
different classes
time and
so basically at mediterrane time we are
kind of creating our own labels
and then it meta test time
um we're using real labels
yeah
process as first you have the
unsupervised projection to a low
dimensional space and then each
task is learning a distortion of that
space that moves some images closer
together in other images farther away
and then if so can you characterize the
kinds of distortions that can be learned
via this process like there's a kind of
a family of allowable Transformations
right
yeah so you can definitely view this as
um like distorting the space in
different ways and then learning like uh
learning to classify for those different
distortions
um you're asking other ways to kind of
characterize the kinds of distortions
that could be represented
it's a lot on the initial web supervised
clustering like you really just
transferred a lot of the burden
and if it produces clusters that don't
correspond to all of your meta test
tasks you're going to have a hard time
and so then it seems like it's limited
by like well how much can you distort or
change the space after it's been
instructed by that process yeah
absolutely so it's going to rely a lot
on on the initial clustering and I guess
I should clarify that we
um in this method you cluster more than
once and
um you could uh I if I remember
correctly the before clustering more
than like each time we scaled and I
think we like kind of Applied some kind
of random scaling uh to the
um
to the embedding and that was one way to
distort it you could also Imagine
fancier ways to distort the space as
well uh you could also run it like you
could also have multiple pre-trained
representations and presumably they'll
have different things that they pick up
on or different high level features and
that may give you even more diverse
tasks and so this really connects to
like the diversity of tasks that you get
and I suspect that there's
in general it seems like it's actually
able to learn pretty diverse tasks that
seem to cover things pretty well
especially given that the Gap here is
only like a nine percent gap between
supervised but there's probably also a
lot of room for improvement
um and these were results with mammal
and mini image.505 shot but it also you
kind of see a similar
um a similar Trend with different
embedding methods with different data
sets
um and also with prototypical networks
um project pool numbers did under
perform in some cases but
um in general they're both able to do
pretty well
cool um so that was one way to construct
tasks and um coming back to some of what
we saw with contrastive learning you can
also construct tasks in a very similar
to way to what we um to what we saw with
contrastive learning so
um
we four image data in particular we know
that an image label won't change if you
apply certain Transformations like if
you drop out some of the pixels or
translate the image a little bit or
reflect the image and so if you take
Omni lot and you apply a transform like
this or if you kind of flip a mini image
that image you the kind of the
underground underlying categorization of
the image won't change
and so we can use this to construct
tasks so we can construct tasks in the
same exact way as what we saw in
contrastive learning where we first
randomly sample some images assign a
label to those images
and then for each of those images we
also augment those images in some way
and then assign the same label to those
and then the first image that becomes
our support set and the second becomes
our query set
um and you could also augment in a
different way your for your support set
as well if you didn't want to use the
original images
um
and so in practice you can use whatever
you know about the image domain so for
omnigot you would use something like
translation and pixel Dropout you
wouldn't want to flip the image because
that may actually flip the flip the the
category label of that character
um whereas for mini image that you you
would probably do things like flipping
um and so
um these Auto augment here which
corresponds to a number of different
transformations
and
um
if you use this approach to for task
construction
um it gets really strong Omni glot
performance
uh in particular the performance is kind
of in the 80s to 90s on Omni glot in
many cases uh and in the five shot
setting this actually gets pretty close
to a fully supervised bass line on Omni
glut and this makes sense because we
know a lot about the structure of omni
lot images
um we have a lot of domain knowledge
about that
um whereas for mini image that ends up
doing somewhat similarly to the
clustering approach that we talked about
before uh
and in some cases it's kind of slightly
underperforms that approach and that
also makes sense we have I think a
little bit less domain knowledge about
um about the kind of Transformations
that will affect
um natural images
cool um so those were a couple examples
with images and how to construct images
with how to construct tasks when you
have unlabeled images
you can also apply the same recipe with
text as well with a different task
construction technique
one option which we've seen before is
the is to formulate a language modeling
problem where a sequence the support set
is a sequence of characters and the
query set is as the following sequence
of characters and
um we've seen this kind of example where
uh the inner loop of the meta learning
process
kind of goes through each of these
examples you might have these examples
as your support set and these examples
as your query set
um and you have different tasks like uh
translating between languages math
problems or spelling correction
um so this is an example a way to
construct meditating tasks with just
purely unlabeled text
but we might not want to use this option
in all cases uh for example it may be
harder to combine with optimization
based meta learning and it's also not
necessarily the best suited for kind of
simple binary classification tasks
um the second option which we is
basically the kind of other form of
generative pre-training we talked about
is to use uh math language modeling
and the tasks here will just correspond
to masking different words
and concretely the way that you can do
this is um
for a given task
sample a set of unique words of n unique
words and assign each of those words a
unique ID
so for example you could sample the word
Democratic and the word capital
and assign an idea of one to democratic
an idea of two two capital
and then you can sample
sentences with
um with one of those two words
and mask out the word
and then the task is to classify
um which word was masked out
and so this is going to give you an ny
classification problem if you sample n
words because you'll be basically be
given okay for these n words which of
those words is corresponds to the masked
out word
and this allows you to construct a kind
of text classification problems without
actually having access to any
labeled Text data
and so kind of concretely for the
Democratic and capital example
we can have a support set that looks
like this where M corresponds to the
massed out word the sentence corresponds
to the input the class corresponds to
the label
and we have two examples from class one
and two examples from class two
and then the query will correspond to a
new sentence that also has a word masked
out and you need to be able to predict
whether or not the label is one or two
or basically whether or not the word is
Democratic or capital
cool
um so with this kind of approach you can
apply it either in a fully unsupervised
way or you could actually
um and really with the other approaches
too you can combine it with some
supervised tasks if you have some tasks
available
and so
um here are some kind of what the
results look like if you either apply it
in a fully unsupervised way
um or everything on kind of the right
hand side of the table is if you um is a
kind of a more semi-supervised or
supervised approach
um Bert corresponds to kind of what we
talked about last week with standard
self-supervised learning
um smlmt is the proposed unsupervised
approach
UM multitask Bert corresponds to
multitask learning and fine-tuning on
the supervised tasks
um there's also an optimization based
metal learner that's applied only to the
supervised tasks as well as a hybrid
method that does meta learning on the
proposed tasks and the supervised tasks
so this is more of like a
semi-supervised metal learning approach
um and what we see is the
um by incorporating these tasks use on
generated from the unlabeled data it's
able to do significantly better than
only using the label data and also
um but only using the label data both
for
um
does multitask learning and also for
meta learning and also we see that the
um
for the each of these different text
classification problems in many cases
this is able to
um
or in some cases is able to outperform
like a burnt based pre-training
um cool this is already a lot of results
but if you want more results there's uh
kind of more in the paper that's linked
cool um so
in the second part of this lecture we
talked about kind of this form of
unsupervised pre-training it ends up
looking a lot like
the unsupervised pre-training that we
talked about last week where we saw Mass
language modeling we saw Auto aggressive
language modeling
um we saw like generating tasks from
augmentations
um
it has this kind of recipe of given an
unlabeled data set proposed tasks with
these different techniques and then run
meta learning on it and really the key
difference between these methods and the
ones that we saw last week is that we're
actually going to be explicitly running
meta learning and using kind of the
metal learner to perform few shot
learning rather than just doing kind of
fine tuning on top of this pre-trained
on top of some pre-trained
representation
um and we also covered a few different
ways to propose tasks
um that have been suggested in Prior
work uh which includes classifying
between augmented images and different
image instances and like classifying a
Max a masked word
um
cool any questions on yeah
give it enough
um test test data or given like give
enough data on the on the The Meta test
task
yeah
so the question is if you have enough
meta test data
um would kind of the unsupervised
pre-training methods that fine-tune the
representation start to outperform what
we've talked about and yeah the the
answer is yes so these kind of
approaches are really going to shine if
you're in a few shot regime at meta test
time because they're explicitly
optimizing for future learning and the
settings in which unsupervised
pre-training are going to do well are
settings where you have a bit more data
of your target task
um because you're not actually you don't
need to explicitly optimize for future
learning you can simply fine tune
um with a reasonable starting point
actually in the future right so um
yeah this is a great question so all of
these tasks it's a good observation so
all of these tasks
um
like you see this m token this math
token in the sentences and a test time
you often won't have mass tokens and so
I think that's part of the reason why um
this is particularly well suited as my
supervised approach more so than an
unsupervised approach
um I think if you really kind of go
through these numbers carefully be nice
if they if there was like a bar plot but
if you go through them quickly or more
thoroughly you'll see that the
semi-supervised approach is more
performant
um and I suspect that this is because
there's a bit more of a distribution
shift between the unlabeled tasks and
the label tasks foreign
better than all of the approaches that
use label data I'm not sure exactly why
that's the case I'd have to kind of look
at the paper a little bit more closely
but
um yeah it's kind of an interesting
finding
awesome
um cool so
um that's it for today